>> From the Library of
Congress, Washington, D.C.
>>Mary Jane Deeb: OK,
well welcome to the Africa
and the Middle East Reading
Room, to the Division.
I'm Mary Jane Deeb.
I'm Chief of the Division
and I am really delighted
to see you all here today
for what I know is going
to be a very exciting
program with Edmund Ghareeb.
In a little while he
will be fully introduced
by our colleague Nawal
Kawar, but I just want
to add my little bit that
Edmund is an old friend.
And as you all know --
we all have grey hair --
and it goes back many
decades, our friendship.
At least I met you in Beirut
and we continued being
friends for decades at least.
And we even started the new
millennium together in 2000.
But Edmund is a very
special person
who has written extensively,
traveled all over the world,
and written on topics that are
always current: the Middle East,
Iraq, the Kurds, and much more.
Edmund is -- also his
books are here as part
of our collection
at the library.
And I always say something
about us, about our division,
about the library when I
introduce our programs.
Our division, as
many of you know,
is made up of three sections.
The Near East section is the
largest, both in terms of staff
and in terms of the collections
that we have custody of.
The second section -- and the
Near East extends from Morocco
to Afghanistan through
central Asia and the Caucuses.
It's the Arab world.
It is Turkey.
It is Iran.
It is the past and the present.
So it's a very extensive
collection that we hold.
We also have Hebraica which
includes collections from all
over the world in
Hebrew and Yiddish.
And we are responsible for
Africa, for the whole continent
of Africa, and its collections
are all over the library.
And we are custodians
only of a small part
of the African collections.
We have specialists who
speak the many languages
of the regions, who read
it, and who can advise,
and who are themselves scholars.
So I'm always very proud of
our staff here in the division
because of the breadth and depth
of their knowledge
of our materials.
We serve these collections.
So whenever you want
to do research,
please don't hesitate to come.
We've had major exhibits.
We have programs.
We have displays.
And we have, of course,
wonderful scholars who come.
And they come to inform
us, to enlighten us,
to teach us about the research
and the use they have made
of the collections
in the library.
And they are the interpreters
in a way of our collections.
They make everyone understand
better that which we hold sacred
in a way, which we
preserve and hold here
at the Library of Congress.
And so we're always delighted
to have brilliant scholars come
and inform us like today.
So now I will pass the
baton on to Nawal Kawar,
our specialist here
in the division.
And Nawal has organized
this program
and sent you all invitations and
so she will introduce Edmund.
Thank you.
>> Nawal Kawar: Thank
you all for coming.
It was a pleasure to have
our wonderful scholar,
Dr. Edmund Ghareeb.
He's a Lebanese American
scholar who taught
at George Washington
University Elliot School
of International Affairs,
the University of Virginia,
Pepperdine University,
and McGill University.
He earned his BA from the
American International College,
math, and PhD from
Georgetown University.
He's an internationally
recognized expert
on the Middle East, the Iraq
courts, the Arab American media,
and US-Arab relations.
Dr. Ghareeb is the first Mustafa
Barzani Distinguished Scholar
in Global Kurdish Studies
at the American University
in Washington, D.C.
He was the first
to introduce irregular courses
on Kurdish history, politics,
and culture to be taught
in the United States.
For several years he coordinated
the Middle East Studies Program
at American University and the
School of International Service
and taught at Georgetown
University School
of Foreign Affairs in Qatar
and Washington, D.C. He served
as President of the Arab
American University Association
of the Shaybani Society
of International Law.
He has worked as a
journalist and media consultant
and commentator as follows.
His most recent work is a
coauthored report entitled,
"Iraqi Refugees: Their
History, Cultures,
and Background Experiences."
One of his books, The
Historical Dictionary of Iraq,
was described in the
Library Journal as one
of the best referenced works
on Iraq published in
the United States.
He has also authored Split
Vision: The Portrayal of Arabs
in the American Media, and is
a coauthor of War in the Gulf,
published by Oxford
University Press.
He's the author and coauthor
of several widely acclaimed
books including the Kurdish
Nationalist Movement in 1973;
The War in the Gulf, 2001;
The Kurdish Question
in Iraq, 1981.
He was the editor of
several books and monographs,
including Split Vision:
The Portrayal of Arabs
in the American Media
and Perspectives
on the United Arab Emirates.
He authored and coauthored about
11 books and monographs dealing
with the issue of Iraq, the
Kurds, the Arabian peninsula,
the fertile crescent region,
the technology evolution
in the Arab world,
and the ethnic
and religious groups
in the Middle East.
Dr. Ghareeb has lectured widely
in the US, the Arab world,
and Europe as well as
in Brazil and Hong Kong.
He has written articles
about the courts, the rules,
the Libya for the Encyclopedia
of Foreign Politics
and Religion.
Dr. Ghareeb is one of the most
widely interviewed experts
on topics related to Iraq,
ethnic and religious identity
in the Middle East, and
is a regular commentator
for the BBC Arabic Television,
Algerian TV, Abu-Dhabi TV,
Al-Arabiyya TV, and Al
Jazeera since its inception.
He has been interviewed for
documentaries by the following:
Al Jazeera on Kurdish
leader Mustafa Barzani,
Lucas Film on Gertrude Bell,
the History of the Arab American
immigration to the US for Voice
of America, and Arab
Americans on the Alhurra,
and Radio Deutsche
[inaudible] among others.
He is at present Senior
Scholar at the Jerusalem Fund.
Without further ado, please
help me welcome Dr. Ghareeb.
[ Applause ]
>> Edmund Ghareeb:
Thank you very much.
Thank you, Mary Jane, for
that kind introduction,
and also Nawal, many thanks.
That's very kind.
I don't know if you
were talking about me
or somebody else [laughing]
with that kind introduction.
But Marius and Mary Jane and I
have been many close friends,
as Mary Jane mentioned,
for a long time.
And I've been always an
admirer of both of their works
and I'm grateful for their
friendship, as I am also
for the friendship of many
of you who are here today.
You know, one of the things
that I wanted to focus on,
I'll try to focus on -- it's
a big topic, by the way,
and I'll try to be as brief
about some of the points
as I can but I'll be
happy if we have the time
to answer some questions later
on during the discussion.
But I want to talk
about this press
because in the Arab
American press,
the Arabic language specifically
press in the United States
because it has been a -- you
know, some of these papers,
one of the papers, Al-Hoda,
which was published in 1898,
actually survived
until the 1991-92.
And it was the second longest
surviving Arabic language
newspaper after Al-Ahram.
So that's something
quite, quite unusual.
And actually they also --
and I will talk a little bit
about that later -- they
made some very significant
technological contributions
which were used
by the Arab press later on.
One of the things
is that the life
of the Arab press has
not received a great deal
of attention by scholars.
There have been some
reports, some studies, a few,
a couple of books, a
few books here and there
about the Arabic language
press in the United States.
Although the press was
mentioned as early as 1922,
as one of the main ethnic
presses in the United States
by Professor Robert
Park who did the first
and the most significant
study on the ethnic presses
in the United States
until that time.
Nevertheless, not
much has been done.
What's unfortunate is that
while there's this rich history
and this treasure of the
Arabic language newspapers,
unfortunately many
of them are missing.
Some we don't know what
has happened to them.
Maybe some of them are still
somewhere in the attics of some
of the Arab Americans,
Lebanese-American immigrants,
or the children or grandchildren
because many of the children
or grandchildren didn't know
Arabic, didn't appreciate,
didn't know what they had.
And I know several people --
and I know this from
personal experience --
threw away some of these papers
and books that were published
in Arabic in the United States.
But we should be grateful,
actually, for the work done
by people at the
Library of Congress.
It was started by the
former head of this section,
Dr. George Atrilla,
the late George Atrilla
who actually did amazing work
actually trying to get some
of these newspapers, magazines,
and books into the library.
And Mary Jane has
continued with this effort
because this is really
a significant,
as I've said, treasure.
There are some amazing
things in these papers.
But and there is a need,
actually, to try to preserve
and protect what's
left out there.
I also used -- more than once
-- used the library here.
And actually one of
the former librarians,
or one of your former
colleagues, Dr. George Saleem,
who is very knowledgeable about
the Arab American literature --
he did his thesis on
Elia Abu Madi who's one
of the great Lebanese
poets in the [inaudible]
and who was the editor also of
Samir Magazine which survived
for decades, actually,
in the United States.
Although at times
it was a newspaper
and then it changed
into a magazine.
But he helped me find --
I found an article in one
of my father's books which
basically was talking, warning,
about the possibility
of establishing a Jewish
state in Palestine.
And I have the name of the
author and the date which was --
but I didn't know
where it appeared.
And the date wasn't
really clear.
But there was 19.
But that's a long history.
So George Saleem helped direct
me to the work by Henry Milkee
who has done an amazing work
on actually the relationship
between the press
and the Mahjar,
some of the Mahjar writers.
And that is something
that's very unusual.
And I appreciated that.
A friend of mine and I, Dr.
Jenapta Tunji, wrote an article
about this discovery,
this article.
And it was published
about a year ago.
And the article was,
interestingly enough,
written by the least
political of the Majar writers
and that was Mahain
Naime [phonetic].
That was quite significant
that Naime would write
about a political topic.
Well, the Arabic press, there
have been also a number of,
by the way, some other
studies that have been done.
For example, there is
in addition to Milkee,
there has been Alexa Inaff
[phonetic] did some work --
she's an historian -- about
the Arab American experience.
And so also in addition to to
her, Mamadou Mudaleli [phonetic]
and George Saleem did both
the articles on Afifa Karam
who is very interesting.
I'll try to, if we have time,
to talk a little bit about her
and maybe use a couple
few quotes from her.
She was one of the
first woman journalists
in the Arab American
press, people the first.
She later on established
her own magazine,
[foreign language spoken], The
Woman's New World Magazine,
which survived for about two
years between 1912 and to 1914.
But it was amazing the articles,
the topics that she focused on.
But beyond that, even
Parr quoted, actually,
pioneering work in this area.
He said there is a woman
who has written here
but he didn't even
mention her name.
She is also a novelist in
addition to being a journalist
and she has eight
books to her name and
yet she has not received the
attention that she deserves.
Well, in many ways, you know,
something very interesting
about these newspapers,
this press.
You know, between 1892 when the
first newspaper was published
and around 1929-1930
there was something
like 57 Arabic language
newspapers published
in the United States.
And there were something
like 22 magazines published
in the United States
at that time.
There were many others
that came after.
Some of these survived for
a short period but some
of them were there for
decades or years, many years.
And that's something very
unusual when you think
of how small the community was.
The Lebanese American,
Syrian American --
at that time they were all
called Syrians although there
was a push early on by
the editor of Al-Hoda,
Naoum Mokarzel who was one of
the, again, the founders of one
of the major newspapers --
to move away from using
the term Syrian to focusing
on the term Lebanese, at least
for the Lebanese communities
but others continued to use
the term interchangeably.
And so this is what we
saw during this time,
is that you began
to see this movement
that basically created a new
environment, the environment
that made it possible for
the major writers, poets,
historians, novelists to
write in these newspapers.
And that's where we
saw the emergence
of the Mahjar literature.
People like Gibran --
that's where he first wrote.
He first wrote his first
articles in al-Mohajer
which was published
by Ameen Guraieb.
And he published hundreds of
articles in that newspapers
and that's how he first began
to be known in the community.
And the editor of the
paper really helped him
and helped him especially
with his Arabic as well
as with other, you know,
projects that he had.
And in a way this was the
same kind of relationship
that Naoum Mokarzel, the founder
of Al-Hoda newspaper,
had with Afifa Karam.
And I'll talk a little bit if
we have time earlier about it.
Now most of the immigrants who
were here probably by the 1890s,
nobody knows the exact numbers.
There may have been
somewhere around 15,000 people
by the 1890s, maybe
2-300,000 by the early '20s.
So still this community
was small.
But how could this small
community produce so many papers
and so many contributions in
this short period of time?
Part of it, first of
all, especially that many
of these people were
not very well educated.
Many of them came
from small villages
who did not receive
a good education.
Some of them barely -- they
had rudimentary knowledge even
of Arabic.
They didn't know English.
But there was also amongst
these there were people
who were quite well educated and
who knew English, knew French,
knew other languages as well.
And these people
basically benefited
from the renaissance
movement that emerged
in the 19th century
in the Arab world.
And a basic part of it had to
do with the printing presses
that were established
first in Aleppo in the end
of the 17th century, early
18th, and in Lebanon at some
of the monasteries in Lebanon
which at first they
were interested
in publishing religious
texts and then
after that they turned back to
publish early Arabic treasures
in poetry, in literate, in
history, religion, etc.,
etc. Also, the second one had
to do with missionary schools
that were established by
American missionaries,
French missionaries, some
other Europeans, Russians.
There was -- the Russians,
for example, opened schools
for the orthodox Christians.
It was known as the
Palestine Oriental Society.
That's where somebody like
[inaudible] have studied.
And Naoum ended up
studying in Russia.
But American missionaries
also played a major role
because they opened
schools and colleges as well
in the whole region from Egypt
to Turkey to Iraq and Iran
as well, and of course
Lebanon, Syria,
Palestine benefited a great
deal from these schools.
And of course especially the
Syrian Protestant College
which later on became known
as American University was
a very important center
for learning in these areas.
This is where they learned
European languages in a way.
They opened their, you know,
their minds to works by writers
from other countries,
particularly
from Europe and beyond.
So the tiny elites among
the immigrants were the
beneficiaries of this cultural
renaissance which resulted
from the enlightenment policies
which were pursued at least
in Lebanon from the Maanad
and the Shihabi princes
who opened the country
up to foreign ideas
and to western missionaries.
The missionaries, of course,
went there to convert Muslims.
They didn't succeed.
They didn't do a very good job.
And I don't think they would
have been convincing in any way.
There were only a handful of
Muslim converts but they ended
up converting some
Middle Eastern Christians
to their own faith or sects.
One of the -- also and that's
why we had the first Arabic
newspapers, actually.
The first Arabic newspaper, by
the way, was started by Napoleon
when he invaded Egypt.
But a couple of years
later that newspaper died.
But the first private Arabic
newspaper was established
by Rizqallah Hassun
who was from Aleppo.
And he published a very
important newspaper and later
on he also published the
paper and moved it to Egypt
because the atmosphere in Egypt
was much freer at that time.
Then it was mostly the Lebanese
and to a lesser extent
the Syrians
who were publishing
newspapers in the Middle East.
In fact, most of the
newspapers that were published
at that time were
started by the Lebanese.
And if we take a look,
for example, in Egypt,
you had Al-Ahram
newspaper, for example.
[Inaudible] were
started by Lebanese.
Also, al-Muqtataf Magazine
and Al-Hilal Magazine were also
started by Lebanese journalists.
And that's primarily because
of the much freer environment
that existed at that
time in the area.
One of the things that I think
is very important to remember is
that we -- when, you know, these
immigrants first started coming
to the United States,
actually it was newspapers
that they first started.
These were the first
institutions they built.
They built these
institutions before they began
to build churches or mosques.
And that's something very --
when you think of
it very unusual
because if you take a look
at some of the newspapers
that would emerge later
on you'd find that some
of the papers were
very sectarian.
They were newspapers
that supported,
defended the orthodox Christians
against the Maronites
and others.
There was a Maronite newspaper,
two Maronite newspapers,
basically defending
the Maronite community.
Basically you had a newspaper
that defended and sort
of supported the Druze community
and the Muslim community.
But then you also had
newspapers that spoke
for the community as a whole.
And who defended
actually the community
as a community regardless?
And there were many
of the writers who,
especially the Mahjarwriters,
prominent writers,
people like Amina
Rohani, like Gibran,
like Mikhail Anaymi [phonetic]
who denounced sectarianism
and denounced that tendency.
Rohani wrote, actually,
a very important article
denouncing the presses,
the newspapers, and
he blamed them
for actually devaluing the role
of the press and urged them
to rise above their
sectarian conflict.
So basically you had
others, as I said, however,
that had either more of
a pan-Arab kind of view
or even the ones that
were either pro-Lebanese
or pro-Syrian.
But primarily many of them
were secular and non-sectarian
and they defended the
community as a whole.
One of the interesting things
that happened, actually,
and where we saw the
unity of the community
and the important role that
newspapers, the presses played,
and it was when around 1907
the US government banned,
stopped immigration
from the Middle East.
And primarily they considered
the people from the Middle East
as non-Caucasian Asians.
And so the other thing
is they made it difficult
for them to get citizenship.
That's when the community
led, interestingly enough,
by two people who were fighting
at that time [laughing] almost
tooth and nail with each other.
And these were basically
Najeeb Diab who was the editor
of Meraat ul Gharb --
the Mirror of the West --
and Naoum Markezel who
was the head of Al-Hoda.
They were -- almost every week
they were attacking each other.
But when this issue came
up they joined together.
They joined something like
what you might call a lobby
and they came to Washington.
Actually that was the title
of one of the articles
by one of the writers.
He said onto Washington.
And so they united and they
were able to change the position
of the government at that time.
The press, actually -- and
there were a number of them.
Maybe if we can look at them,
some of them, I'll show you
at least some of the photos
of some of these papers.
But they played a
very important role.
Thank you.
They played a very important
role in this area in the sense
that they were -- first of
all, they were [inaudible].
For example, during
the First World War --
and I know this from
personal, by example,
because I know my relatives who
had immigrated to this country
at that time would tell me
that the news of the war,
the First World War, the news
that people were dying of hunger
or starvation, of the
executions that took place
under [inaudible] of
politicians, of activists,
nationalists, were
actually making many people
in the community
very much concerned
about what was going on.
And the way to find out what
was happening was primarily
through the newspapers that
were here at that time.
You know, the second thing is
that they also expressed these
thoughts, the immigrants,
a great deal about
the United States.
There were a number of
them who published books
about the American Constitution
in Arabic, about American laws.
They published also about the
history of the United States.
Several books, actually,
came out, were published
about the history of the
US and also how to deal
with their day-to-day life.
That was something that
was basically very,
very important during
this period.
In addition, some of these
papers, especially Al-Hoda,
actually were financially
successful.
By the early '30s,
around 1931-32,
they had 30,000 subscribers
from all over the world.
Most of them, of course, were
from the United States but some
of them were from Latin
America, all different countries
in Latin America,
where by the way,
there was also a vibrant
Arabic language press.
In fact, the Arabic
language press
in South America started before
the Arabic language press
in the United States.
The first press newspaper was
established in Brazil in 1890.
And so what we saw during
this period is that we began
to see these newspapers
also had sections --
for example, a section
talking about your doctor.
So basically if you're
having a problem,
you wrote to the newspaper.
You wrote a letter to the doctor
who would answer the questions
which was in many
ways very modern,
something like what
we have been hearing
about basically our
people on radio
and television these
days doing it.
But that was very
quite interesting.
They had also, they said,
your immigrant advisor.
Basically if you had
problems, legal problems,
if you had any questions
to do, how to, for example,
establish a company
or anything like that.
They also had somebody who
would write a weekly column
about this.
Maybe we can just take a look
at some of these newspapers.
Al Bahrayn, which is a
very, very important paper.
And this was established
by Samiam Abdul
and Abbas Abu Abushepra
[phonetic] at that time.
And it was an excellent
paper, actually.
In the beginning its
attitudes, its perspective was
in the beginning
somewhat an Islamic
but then it became pan-Arab
and what was critical
and as time went by they
became much more secular.
The [inaudible] who
some of you may know,
a very eloquent speaker and
a scholar and a good scholar
who used to read Al
Bahrayn regularly,
they said of Al Bahrayn
that this was a newspaper
that did not -- sorry?
Where was it?
>> In New York.
>> Edmund Ghareeb:
In New York, yeah.
And later on, however, it
moved after it was taken
over by Rajid Bahar,
another prominent journalist,
and he moved it to Detroit.
But basically it
was in New York.
So he said, Faid Sael said,
he said this newspaper is not
going to fabricate stories.
We'll not fabricate any story.
And they will not censor any
story because something's bad
and we don't want
to hear about it.
So and he used the
term, actually,
it's almost an exact translation
for what we're hearing a lot
about these days, the fake news.
He said, we'll never
publish fake news.
So it's a fascinating paper.
Another paper was [foreign
language], actually.
It was started by
Shebelle Damouz [phonetic]
around 1906, I think.
And at that time he
was primarily focusing
on literary issues, cultural
issues, historical issues.
He didn't basically do some
of the things that Al-Hoda
or Meraat ul Gharb did like
your doctor and your advisor,
etc. And later on it was picked
up by Fawzi Lebraydi [phonetic]
who is from the same hometown
as Damouz and it was published
and then moved at
one time to Detroit.
I had the privilege of
meeting recently the daughter
of Fawzi Lebraydi and I was
asking her about how did she --
she lives in New York.
How did her father
finance his newspaper?
And she said -- she laughed.
She said, well sometimes he got
it from basically advertising
and that's something
very also interesting
and this is something
clearly American in the sense
that these newspapers rely to a
large extent on advertisements.
And they made, like
Al-Hoda made a lot of money
from these advertisements.
But she said he did that but
he also relied on friends.
And sometimes -- it was
the paper started weekly.
By twice a week.
And then when money
wasn't coming in,
he changed it to weekly.
And then he had to go
travel from state to state
to get some friends to
contribute some money for him
to keep the newspaper going.
But he also had -- [inaudible]
was quite interesting
in the sense that it focused
a great deal of attention
on developments in
the Arab world also
and in Lebanon and Syria.
They supported the independence
of the Arab countries,
self-determination.
They supported -- they
wrote, for example,
about Abd al-Karim El-Khattabi
in Morocco who was one
of the rebel opposing
colonial control.
They focused on what was
happening in Tunisia.
So it's quite interesting.
Another thing that another
newspaper we have is like --
let me give you a
look at Al-Hoda.
Al-Hoda is quite, it's probably
actually, as I mentioned
in the beginning, it's the
most influential newspaper.
It had excellent -- the
editor had excellent command
of the Arabic language.
He emphasized the significance
that he has a publication
that's written in very eloquent
and correct grammatically
Arabic,
unlike his brother Salloum
who later would establish one
of the first English language
magazines in the United States
between 1926 and 1932 which
was probably the best magazine
that had appeared
talking about the region.
And this was known
as The Syrian World.
It had people like
Gibran, like Phillip Hitti,
like [indecipherable name],
Rihani, and many others as well
as American writers
contributing to it.
They had political articles.
They had historical articles.
They had a great deal of
literary works, translations
from Arabic literature
to English.
They had sections focusing on
developments in the Arab world
at that time in different
Arab countries.
Of course, the main focus
was mostly Lebanon, Syria,
to a lesser extent
Iraq, Palestine,
but that was something
that was very significant.
In addition to to this, if
we can take a note, also,
to another newspaper,
maybe, Meraat ul Gharb.
This is the paper which really
was the competitor of Al-Hoda.
And this was published
by Najeeb Diab.
Najeeb Diab basically supported
more or less an orthodox view,
the orthodox Christian
perspective, at that time.
Najeeb Diab actually
was very critical.
While Naoum Markezel
was somewhat soft
on the Ottoman government --
he was careful because he had
also some correspondence there
and some subscribers.
But he later on would
become also a severe critic
of the Ottoman government.
Meraat ul Gharb from the
beginning was a severe critic
of the Ottoman government and
called for independence of that
of the Arab-speaking lands.
They even opened the
door sometimes for a call
if there should be a caliphate
should the caliphates would
return to the Arabs.
It would not be in the Ottoman.
And but Najeeb Diab was
sentenced to death when he was
in the Middle East because
of his political activities
and he fled.
And his property was
expropriated by the government.
And he fled the year later.
By the way, Naoum
Markezel and a number
of other editors were
sentenced to death
by the Ottoman government
and some, by the way,
who were in the Middle East
were executed, were caught
and some were imprisoned.
If we can just take a
look at the Neisser,
one of the other papers.
That's the paper.
I was interested
in it personally
because my father used to write
some articles in this paper.
It used to be known as The
Syrian Eagle and it was
by another very activist
nationalist editor Najeeb
Badran, who also emphasized
a great deal not only
on the literary side but
on the political side.
But the mirror art was very
similar to Al-Hoda in the sense
that they had a great deal of
emphasis on the literary work
because primarily when we think
of it, Gibran actually wrote,
learned, and much of what
although later he would write
in other papers he started,
as I said, in Al-Mouhajir,
the newspaper of [inaudible].
Rohani, although
he later on broke
with his relative Naoum
Markezel, the editor of Al-Hoda,
that's where he started
his writing was in Al-Hoda.
Later on, however,
while Markezel adopted a
Lebanese nationalist respect --
he established the Lebanese
National Organization,
he called for the
independence of Lebanon --
Rohani adopted what you might
call a pan-Arabist perspective
and so he broke away from Naoum
Markezel and began to write
in some of the other
publications.
For example, Asser [phonetic]
which is another
important publication.
I don't know if we have a --
I don't think we
have a picture of it.
Asser was established by
Abdul Messi Habdid [phonetic]
who is a Syrian from Homs.
It was a Syrian nationalist
newspaper.
It said basically they
believed there was no difference
between Lebanese
Syrians, Palestinians,
Jordanians, or Iraqis.
They should all be --
[inaudible] one Syria.
But he also opened the doors
to people like Nedra Haddad,
for example, was one of
the prominent writers,
William Hetsfleez [phonetic],
Gibran, [inaudible],
and a number of others,
Phillip Hechty, [inaudible],
they began to write
in this paper.
And it survived,
actually, up until the '50s.
Let me quickly just mention
a couple of things I wanted
to mention about 'Af?fa Karam
who was a very unusual --
I mean, I didn't know much
about her in the beginning
but when I was looking at some
of the material about her.
She left Lebanon -- she was
born in 1883, married in 1897.
She was 14 years old when
she got married to a doctor
who was a distant
relative of her family.
It was an arranged marriage
and she came to this country.
She had studied in some of the
catholic schools in Lebanon
and in some of her local schools
but she came from a family
that had connections
with a prominent school
of [foreign language]
and from the village
of Croshema [phonetic].
It's [inaudible] which had --
that's where people like the
Bostanais and others had,
you know, had the renaissance
of the Arabic language
and the Arabic literature.
And so she was interested
in, even from that time.
When she got to the
United States about a year
or two later she read an article
that was written by a priest.
And she didn't like what he was
saying about the role of woman.
So she wrote an article and
basically criticizing him.
Then she wanted to
pull the article back.
She thought she went too far.
But Naoum Merkezel encouraged
her, edited it for her.
And later on she began
to ask him for books.
She was living in Louisiana
with her husband and he told her
that if she wants to
write he would help her
and improve her Arabic so
that she could write well
and also write articles.
And he said she can write
about any topic she wants.
And she was actually one
of 600 American woman
journalists at that time.
There were only 600
American women
who were journalists
during this period.
But she focused -- much
of her work focused
on liberty and freedom.
She was both criticizing
and praising these concepts
in the American context.
And while she praised the
American idea of freedom,
Karam also asserted
that America is one
of the most dangerous
countries for young people given
to high cost of living and
expectations of lavishness
which could put youth at risk
entering the workforce in order
to make money by
any means necessary.
Karam's womanhood played
a very important role
in her writing.
She stated that she did not
become a writer for fame
or money but rather to advance
the issues of her fellow women.
And she was known
to be the voice
of the Arab women's
liberation movement.
And she published one of
the four magazines devoted
to women's issues in the
whole Arabic speaking world
at that time.
So one of them was here.
Later on there was
another paper,
although it was not
just focusing on women.
That was called [foreign
language].
I think -- do we
have a picture of it?
I think we --
>> Is that a newspaper?
>> Edmund Ghareeb:
It's a magazine.
And so basically -- no.
So that was published by
Apubref Ayel [phonetic]
and it also was quite
an impressive paper.
Let me use one quote
from what she said.
She said just women have
the right to newspapers.
She criticized newspapers
including Al-Hoda
because they were not devoting
enough time for women's issues.
She said women are subscribers
and pay their subscriptions
like men.
Women are still behind
in reforming themselves
on their own.
Thus they need the
support of men.
This is why she wrote we
need to have more articles,
more publications,
devote themselves
to the issues of women.
She was not only a defendant
of women's issues but one
of the interesting things about
her, she also was very critical
of the way African Americans,
black Americans were
being treated also
in the United States
at that time.
And she wrote a number
of articles about this.
And she was very much
opposed to violence.
But primarily all of
these publications,
they helped link the
people of the Diaspora
and the Arab-American community
with their home and
their old homes.
They linked them with the other
immigrants in North America,
South America, Canada.
They also did something else.
They began to help modernize
the way newspapers function.
They began to learn from
the American experience how
to write this happened with
the [inaudible] of America,
the star of America which
was the first newspaper.
And they began to
put the quick summary
in the beginning of the article.
And they tried to separate --
although it wasn't
always the same
but we have the same
problem today --
separate opinion from news.
And so in many ways this was a
very significant contribution
that they made.
They also introduced -- that's
what I wanted to mention earlier
about the linotype machine by
the brother of Naoum Merkezel,
Salloum Merkezel, the
editor of The Syrian World.
He basically used a
typesetting machine
and he modernized it
basically to use Arabic letters
in a much easier
way and a faster way
to publish Arabic
newspapers or books.
And this machine, the linotype
machine, was imported later
on first by Allah
Haram in Egypt and then
by other Arabic language
newspapers.
So they really, they
also had correspondence.
They had correspondence
and assembled in Damascus
and Cairo and Cuba and Havana.
So this was quite,
quite significant.
So basically this was they
began to decline basically
from the '30s, although
they continued.
But I think overall we can say
that they made a difference
and they added color to
the American rainbow.
Let me just show you some
pictures maybe of some
of the books that have been
and the magazines
that were published.
One of the magazines I
didn't mention was Al-Funun.
Al-Funun was probably one
of the -- it was published,
started to be published
in 1912 by Nasib Arida.
And he attracted -- Naimy became
one of its editors at one time.
He focused on literary issues.
He focused on cultural
issues, on poetry, on novels,
and was very, very impressive.
And it looked beautiful.
It was -- from every
angle you looked
at it it was quite impressive,
whether it was the printing,
the subject matter,
the topics, etc.
Let me show you just quickly and
[inaudible] -- where is it here?
[Inaudible] This is the paper
that I was mentioning
whereby focus was not on --
it was one of the few magazines
that focused on women's issues.
And I don't know if
you can read the titles
of some of the articles.
That will give you
an interesting idea
of what they wanted
to talk about.
Let us -- also quickly let me
show you some of the other books
that were published
by the Arabic Language
Press in the United States.
Yes?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
This [foreign language
spoken], this was done
by Abdul Messi Hadded
[phonetic] and it was
with the help of Nasib Arida.
They had basically -- first of
all they wrote the introduction
of the history of
the immigration
to the United States,
the history of Syria,
then they had the names
of businesses and/or
organizations --
different kinds of organization,
social, civic, religious,
etc. -- in the United States.
One of them that
was very interesting
to me it was called
the Syrian Israelite
Charitable Association.
So it was very interesting.
This was in 1930, around '29-30.
So there was an organization
because this was apparently
Jews, you know, from Lebanon
and Syria who considered
themselves
to be Syrians at that time.
Let me show you The
Syrian World.
It's just the cover of it.
This is the one Salloum
Merkezel, Naoum's brother --
and he, by the way, after
his brother Naoum died
in 1932 he had to
close The Syrian World
because he wasn't making
enough money at that time.
He was having problems but
he left it to someone else
to edit it and then he went to
take over his brother's paper,
Al-Hoda, and he somewhat changed
the direction of the paper.
[ Inaudible Comments ]
This is -- by the way this
is the Gibran's Processions
which was published
in Arabic in 1949.
And this is a real
book, by the way.
This was a copy that
my father had.
And it has this -- he had given
it to a present to someone else.
And maybe if we can
take a look at that.
By the way, some of the poems
are sang by Farooz today.
But it received some criticism
by like Mahmoud al-Bezla Akahd
[phonetic] because they said
that some of the words
that Gibran was using
were not literary
or were not really
grammatically correct.
And then he was criticized
by Naimy who said,
you know, he's writing poetry.
It's readable poetry.
It's beautiful poetry.
It doesn't matter even if he --
because somebody said something
1,000 years ago that we have
to follow on the same path.
So this is, we can -- let's see.
I had it here.
I was going to show
you at least.
Gibran had given this
to a friend of his,
Maria Garland, in New York.
And there are only
500 copies of this.
Let me show you one more,
Asanabid [phonetic], this one.
This is also a very
rare publication.
This was published
by [inaudible],
friends of Gibran, in 1929.
This one. No, sorry.
This is another one.
Do you see it?
[ Inaudible Comments ]
Yeah. OK. This is
one of the photos
of the -- this is another.
This is the [inaudible] This
is Nasi Haded's newspaper.
And he also issued a special
magazine, a special edition
which was known as
the Sahr [inaudible].
Actually almost all
of the Mahjar writers
would contribute to this.
But to go back quickly
to the Saneb.
This was basically they
printed 500 copies of it only,
as they did up in [inaudible].
Four hundred were
distributed to the people
who attended Gibran's jubilee
in 1929 and 100 were left.
But I haven't seen another
copy of this publication.
Anyway, let's maybe stop here
and take some maybe some
questions or comments.
Then we'll take it from there.
>> Yes.
[ Applause ]
>> Edmund Ghareeb: Please.
>> In this Arabic
renaissance which took place
in New York City, was there an
impetus to modernize the use
of Arabic [inaudible]?
>> Edmund Ghareeb: You
know, this is a -- yeah.
This is a very, very
good question.
There's no doubt that the papers
also saw themselves in some way,
or at least some of the
editors did and you can say
that for people like
Rajid Bahar,
for people like Najeeb Diab,
and to a lesser extent
[inaudible] also
because they wanted
to introduce also --
first of all there
was this renaissance,
a linguistic renaissance.
There's this revolution in form
in the way they wrote Arabic.
It was much simpler,
much easier, much more --
for some at least -- for
many people it was much
more beautiful.
Although others, conservatives,
criticized them and they said
that they were almost heretics
and nevertheless these editors,
some of them, they felt that
they have a duty also to have --
well to learn, to pass
on what they learned
in the United States
whether it was in terms
of technological development,
of principles and ideals
such as freedom of the press
and the right of people to
establish their own governments,
a representative government.
This was one of the messages
that they wanted to send back
to the home, the old country
as they used to call it.
And to spread these ideas.
This was one of the
main messages
that they felt that they had.
They had the same
message also to try
to inform the Arab Americans
or if you want to call them
or Lebanese Americans,
Syrian Americans.
They wanted to inform these
people about what was happening
in the United States,
what was happening
in their own countries.
They wanted them to be, to
assimilate in the United States
but also so that they
could become good citizens
and that they can contribute
not only to their new lands
that they are living in but
they could contribute also
to the old land.
And they were hoping
that they might be able
through these scientific
advancements --
and some of them did
go back, actually.
Some brought back the
technological advances
to the region.
[ Inaudible Question ]
Exactly. It was this.
This was one of the main ideas.
There is no doubt that
they did have an impact.
In the sense, for example, if
you read some of the works,
the writings by some
writers whether it was
in the indifferent
parts of the Arab world.
For example, people
like Asheb in Tunisia
who was a very famous poet.
[Foreign language spoken]
How does the rest go?
[Foreign language spoken].
But basically it was very much
influenced by Gibran's writings.
And so this was something that
was very, very significant
in what they were trying to do.
Yes?
[ Inaudible Question ]
>> And it's kind of
a two-part question.
In this time of intense scrutiny
on the press and xenophobia,
has that had an effect
on [inaudible]?
>> Edmund Ghareeb:
There's no doubt that --
by the way, most of these
publications have passed away,
have died.
Some of them, as I said,
survived like Al-Hoda
for almost 100 years,
almost 100 years.
Some of them survived
for a couple of years
like [foreign language
spoken], The Woman's New World,
[foreign language spoken].
Although she continued
to write in Al-Hoda
and other publications
and other,
[foreign language
spoken], this other paper
which focused on women's issues.
But there was a period
where there was a very
negative reaction to the people
that were still called Syrians.
Sometimes there were also a few
who called them Turks
at that time.
I read this and somebody
else has quoted this.
I don't remember the
name of the congressman.
There was a congressman who
basically was running for office
in South Carolina at
the time of immigration
and he said the Syrians
are the worst of the people
who came either from Asia
Minor or Sicily or Greece.
And he said that if I was to win
with their votes, I
don't want to win.
I'd prefer to have the vote
of the Negroes [laughing]
than have the vote
of the Syrians.
This is this kind
of [laughing] --
I mean, you had this
kind of language
at least among some
of the people.
But overall, I think this
community I think proved they
succeeded at least in
terms of they succeeded
in many ways in the sense first.
Many of them, as I said,
didn't have any education.
They came here.
Some of them carried bags
on their backs and they went
to sell goods in different
parts of the United States.
Some of them became farmers.
But -- and by the way, that
was something very interesting
that has nothing to do with your
question but it's significant
in the sense that one of the
reasons they started coming
to the United States
or to travel.
Of course there was
the religious,
the political oppression.
Both of these were factors.
But also the desire to
have a better way of life.
They heard the news after
the Homestead Act was passed
in the United States by, I
think it was President Lincoln
if I'm not wrong.
That the American king, the king
of America, was giving free land
to peasants, to farmers.
And so that's why
some of them --
actually if you take a look
at where people came from,
most of the people who came
in the beginning, the first,
second wave of immigration came
from very small villages
and towns.
And many of them were farmers
or a few were artisans.
So you know, so this
was quite something
that was quite significant.
But I think they tried whenever
there was pressure on them --
like with the point when
they had difficulty getting
citizenship and later on
when there was an attempt
to ban immigration from there
because they considered them
to be non-Caucasians,
the community, all of it.
And they had a lot of support
from Americans at that time.
And they fought back.
And that was the way.
The other way they believed
that if they succeed
in American society.
They educated their
children, for example.
That's why it ended up many
of them became professionals.
You had a lot of lawyers,
doctors, merchants,
business people in addition to
people who own the, you know,
small stores or who
still work in --
there are all kinds
but generally overall
the community succeed.
[ Inaudible Comments ]
The pictures of the
newspapers, yes.
They are from the
library's selections.
But the books are my books.
They are copies that I have.
And that's why I think it's very
important -- if any of you know,
I think, to try to preserve them
there were something like close
to 500 books that I know
of that were published
in the United States in Arabic.
These included books on
the history of America,
two books on the history
of the French Revolution,
two books on the
history of Russia and one
on the Bolshevik revolution.
They had several books, at
least, on American government,
American laws, the
US Constitution.
There are books,
novels, several novels.
Something that's very unusual
and unfortunately I didn't
find some of these at the time
and I asked some of the
librarians to fine them --
these are books what you'd
call Arabic folk poetry
or zaja [phonetic].
And there were several
books that were published
in this country of zaja poetry.
I have a couple of them,
two or three of them,
but I know that there are
several others out there
and they're not there.
So basically it would be good,
any of us, if you know anybody
who has some of these books
or if you know of anybody
who maybe they would want to
donate them or make copies
of them because once they
are gone they are gone.
>> Dr. Edmund, thank you
so much for [inaudible].
>> Edmund Ghareeb: Thank you.
>> I'd like to ask you
about the newspapers.
You said you got the pictures
from the Library of Congress.
I know the Library of Congress
is doing a [inaudible] --
>> Edmund Ghareeb: This
is what we've written.
>> [Inaudible] America.
Are these newspapers included
in commonplace America?
>> Edmund Ghareeb: This
is -- I should ask you.
>> Mary Jane Deeb:
I have no idea.
Not now. We haven't started
but that's a good idea.
We can start that.
>> Edmund Ghareeb: Ah,
that's a very good point,
very good question.
>> Mary Jane Deeb: Good point!
[ Inaudible Comments ]
>> I've been working
on an article
on [inaudible] American
publishing.
And one of the things that I
discovered about the Library
of Congress is that -- well not
just the Library of Congress
but a lot of things
do get [inaudible].
So I think because the
fees were too high.
[Inaudible] And they
also were coming
from an oppressive government.
They had this fear of
governments in general.
[Inaudible]
>> Edmund Ghareeb: To tell
you the truth I don't know.
But I know for example,
one thing, that the point
that you mentioned about fear of
repressive government in a way.
For example, that editor
of [inaudible] of America,
the first publication.
By the way he was
a medical doctor.
His two sons -- he comes from
the town of Arbil in Syria
where there's a lot of
attacks now taking place.
Although they are changing
the name to Arbin, not Arbil.
Two of his sons -- they came
as a family, the first family
that came to the United
States in the 1870s.
And he found it very difficult
to try to get Arabic letters
so that you could publish,
print the newspaper.
So he had to appeal to the --
he had to get the approval of
the sultans from all the way.
And he was very careful.
He was very pro-Ottoman, almost,
in several of his editorials.
You know, so that, I think,
I'm sure that was a factor
to take into account.
Yeah?
[ Inaudible Comments ]
No, it wasn't, actually.
That's a very good question.
You know, that's why I
was saying that's what's
so interesting about
these papers.
For example, the idea of having
correspondence at that time,
that's amazing when
you think of it.
Having a correspondent in
[inaudible] or in Cairo
or in Damascus or
in Havana, Cuba.
Or you have people
writing from Brazil.
I mean, brought in
a way there a sense
of some globalization taking
place to a certain extent.
But the number of
readers, I think, was --
you know, for example,
probably the highest circulation
newspaper was Al-Hoda and
they had 30,000 subscribers.
But that doesn't mean that these
were the only ones who read it
because sometimes the newspaper
would go from hand to hand.
I mean, I remember
when I first came
to the United States I
would go and sit with some
of the early immigrants
that came.
I liked the stories
that they had.
I always enjoyed it.
And some of them had subscribed
to some of these papers
and they would ask
me to read the paper
for them [laughing] you know?
So that's partly how I
became interested in it.
So that -- and they
would pass the newspaper.
So one person subscribes
but maybe at 15
or 20 people read the paper.
So that --
[ Inaudible Comment ]
And they were read
in the Arab world.
Some of them.
Not everywhere but
there's no doubt there was
strong connection.
There was a very interesting
publication maybe Thomas would
know more about.
Al-Jami'ah was the journal,
magazine, by Farah Antun.
He was a very impressive writer,
intellectual, a secularist --
a secularist among
the secularists.
And he got into a
debate, several debates
with Muhammad Abduh and over in
Al-Menaar and he would respond
with all-Jami'ah over religion.
He published a book about
[inaudible] and some people said
that this was anti-Muslim.
But Egypt still had, you know,
a much more freer
environment than, say,
under the Ottoman government.
And this was published the year
so that was a very
important factor.
Later because he was beginning
to feel uncomfortable
he brought it here.
And this, actually, magazine
focused on philosophical issues,
on scientific issues,
and actually didn't find
much of an audience.
So after three years
he went back to Egypt.
You know, but that's the
-- there was this kind of.
There were writings in
the Egyptian newspaper
about what was being written
in the Mahjar newspapers
and vice versa.
There was a very close
connection with Syria,
with Lebanon, with some of
the other Arab countries.
We have take one more, I
think, or do you have --
[ Inaudible Comments ]
Yes, I would say in the
1930s and the 1940s.
That's when the beginning
of the decline
but there were different waves.
There was the wave, for
example, that came after '67.
The '67 war had a
very important impact
on changing the way Arab
Americans as a whole began
to look at the situation,
then began to organize,
and began to publish
news publications.
There were also some important
English language publications
during this period.
For example, such as George
[inaudible]'s The Arab World.
That was a very important
publication.
It focused on issues related
to the US, its foreign policy,
and also to what was going
on in the Middle East.
And he covered almost
the whole Arab world.
There was also a publication
by George Dibbs called Caravan
which was actually an
excellent publication.
And then we began to
see the revival of some
of these publications by
the different communities.
There were Iraqi newspapers.
There were Egyptian newspapers.
Basically I'm not saying in
the sense that they only appeal
to these communities but they
focus on these communities.
[ Inaudible Comments ]
Me?
Some. Actually that's
a very good question.
I know probably the best places
to find these newspapers: here,
the Library of Congress;
New York Public Library;
the Arab American Museum;
and yes I think there is also
the University of Minnesota
if I am not wrong also has it.
But unfortunately I don't think
we have a complete set of some
of these publications.
There may still be.
I hope they preserve
it -- Estefan.
Faris Estefan who basically took
over Al-Hoda in its last years.
He bought it but the editors
were very prominent Arab poets
like Hari Ghrezb [phonetic]
and Yusuf Hufal [phonetic]
who also had been publisher
of Shar magazine,
a poetry magazine.
He also was publishing
and editor Al-Hoda.
But I hear that he
has a complete copy
and that is a priceless treasure
that somebody should
try to get and keep.
>> Mary Jane Deeb:
OK, [inaudible].
[ Applause ]
>> Edmund Ghareeb: Thank you.
[ Inaudible Comments ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.